this is Charles Bronson's life as he
sees it through 47 years behind bars
he's the artist formerly known as
Britain's most violent prisoner
he hopes this exhibition will boost his
bid for parole if we can show that
Charlie does genuinely want to be
released from prison to work on his art
I think there's a definitely a good
chance this can help with his parole for
sure you know why would someone want to
after creating the works that he's
created behind the cell door why
wouldn't he continue that on a larger
scale Prices range from 700 pounds to 30
000 for that you get a series of nine
drawings
it's a bit Korean it's a little bit Grim
but it's you know this part of part of
it's Grim to be in solitary confinement
for 27 years and 47 years in prison so
this is a man's mind
depicting his life Bronson who now calls
himself Charles Salvador has been in
jail so long because of repeated
violence against staff and fellow
prisoners he was originally jailed in
1974 for seven years for armed robbery
on the flying Squad former detective
Peter Kirkham once investigated armed
robbers it scares me to say it but how
long is it before before we see someone
like this
as the new guest on Big Brother on
Friday night would that be wrong if we
did if he gets his parole I personally
yeah I think he would be I I think that
would be just building on someone's
criminal notoriety too far
it's wrong because people simply
shouldn't commit or shouldn't gain from
their crimes
the exhibition also includes many
digital images inspired by the
prisoner's life and art
the organizers say a third of all
profits will be used to buy art supplies
for underprivileged children Martin
brunt Sky News